well absolutely I believe the African
continent would benefit from the event
yes it's located in south africa i have
been inside of cannon for some time and
i know its increased investments in
south africa we've seen investment in
infrastructure transform the landscape
of this country and i believe the more
people come to south africa for the
world cup the more we create a positive
x for the world cup events instead of
curb more companies benefit from that
and with that in mind there is the
possibility that those companies will
have the capacity and ability to flow
through to other countries in the
continent and those create a positive
apply fight for the entire continent of
africa so welcome everybody to the
continent of africa vs south africa for
the world cup